hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about ESM methylene blue auger
also known as E and B auger which is a
bacterial growth medium so it's a growth
medium that has a couple of cool
characteristics it is selective and it
is differential let's talk about what
that means so it is selective selective
for gram-negative bacteria the reason
for this is actually but it contains
dyes that are toxic to Grande positive
bacteria so it's selected for gram
negative bacteria meaning it allows them
to grow it contains these dyes that are
called es NY and methylene blue that's
where it takes its name and those are
toxic to Grande positive bacteria it is
also differential so it's a differential
specifically for a fecal coliform
bacteria for four so for coliform
bacteria differential meaning that it
allows you just by the way they grow on
the plate to distinguish coliform
bacteria from non coliform bacteria now
you might be asking questions about what
coliform means while coliform bacteria
are rod-shaped gram-negative non or
forming bacteria that can be modal or
non motile that can ferment the sugar
lactose which is also found in this
media the affirmative sugar lactose
producing acid and gas as byproducts
coliforms many of them are not actually
harmful to people but a lot of them are
found in the gut of humans and other
animals and so if you have coliform
bacteria showing up in water or food
samples it typically means those samples
have been contaminated by fecal matter
and could contain other day
as pathogens so that's why you might
want to be looking for the presence of
coliform bacteria through a kind of
growth medium like this so let's talk
about how it does its differential
characteristic it uses those dyes the
same guys I mentioned before the same
ones that are toxic to the gram-positive
bacteria that's the eosin y and
methylene blue and it uses these as pH
indicators so these dyes form a dark
purple at low pH and this allows you to
distinguish bacteria that can ferment
the lactose remember that coliforms
ferment lactose producing not only gasp
and acid so an acid will lower the pH
and that will make the the dark purple
color show up so by planting these kinds
of bacteria on a m/v auger
you can determine you can distinguish
those that ferment lactose like e.coli
from those that do not like Salmonella
excuse me like Salmonella and Shigella
and that's because the colonies that do
ferment lactose like e.coli and other
types of coliform bacteria they will
actually be nucleation being nucleate it
just means that the colony has a dark
Center in it from that dye and that's
because the dye absorption increases
when the pH decreases so when the
lactose is fermented the acid product
comes about that lowers the pH which
increases the dye absorption which means
that the is a dark purple pH indicator
dye that gets absorbed by the colony and
gives it a dark Center and so that means
that coliform bacteria will have those
dark nucleated centers
whereas non coliform bacteria the ones
that do not permit the lat
so do not decrease the pH they're not
going to absorb that dye the dye also
isn't going to be changing color in the
same way and so they will have colorless
colonies so coliforms will have dark
centers non coliforms will be colorless
another cool things and be augur
is that some colonies will actually
develop a metallic green soon so this is
very sort of shiny reflective type of
green that's very distinctive and that's
due to the interaction with those guys
that we've been talking about and
particular strong acid end products of
fermentation in specific types of
bacteria
if those bacteria are motile and they
have flagella the movement of the
flagella can also kind of contribute to
that shown the most well-known one is e
coli but also some species of
citrobacter and some species of antara
factor can also have that metallic green
gene something else to keep in mind if
you have some bacteria that are weak
fermenters meaning that they can ferment
the lactose but it's kind of slow and
it's not necessarily a lot the pH isn't
going to change as much because well
acid will be produced it won't be very
much that is going to produce pinkish
colonies so maybe like a faint pink
color it's you know noticeable but not
very strong and so from all of this you
can see that EMB augur have a lot of
ways to distinguish different kinds of
bacteria if it's a weak fermenter you'll
see the pink chain if it is that
metallic green you know it's going to be
one of these types of bacteria if it's
got the the dark Coleen and you know it
is a coliform
and so these are all different ways that
you
can use EMB augur to distinguish these
different types of bacteria if you're
interested in learning about other kinds
of selective and differential media
things like mannitol salt agar or
macconkey agar and check out my playlist
on bacterial growth media that's it for
today and thanks for watching biology
professor